Andrew always appreciate the time you
know I like to give you a blank canvas
what is this lawsuit from Colin
Kaepernick and his attorney all about
yeah good morning my friend Ross good to
be with you as always the thing about
Colin Kapernick suit that's so different
than all these other suits Ezekiel
Elliott Tom Brady is that it's brought
by Kaepernick's attorneys and the NFLPA
who you reference is always fighting the
NFL seems to be a bystander and they
tweeted out something yesterday that
they learned about this suit collusion
case the same time we did in the media
so my first reaction is there's a
backstory here that tells me maybe
things aren't copacetic between Colin
Kaepernick and his Union and for some
reason this is a case being brought by
individual attorney well-known attorney
Mark Geragos who's represented Michael
Jackson among others instead of being
brought by the Union as to the case
itself you know my feelings here really
uphill climb the only way you bring a
collusion suit with any success is you
have some smoking guns or at least one
smoking gun which is a text an email a
record of some communication between two
or more teams saying let's not sign this
guy and that is what collusion is
collusion is not team saying we'd rather
have Brandon Weeden team saying we'd
rather have Ryan Fitzpatrick take a name
teams are all going to if they're guys
their ever get on a stand or something
they'd say yeah we like the guys we have
we like this guy we like that guy didn't
fit the system all the football reasons
we've heard for eight months but if
there's a smoking gun that's a different
case the last thing I'll say is reading
the press release about the lawsuit it
just seems like there's President
President Trump is involved at there
sort of making it as the president
coercing owners into not signing him and
I'm not sure that's even a case I mean
what we have to see
this owner and that owner this GM and
that GM coordinated effort to keep him
out of the league like I said I'm real
uphill climb Ross yeah I mean if that
were the case with Trump then what was
he really that involved going back to
like March and April and and all that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
what do you make of him the NFLPA not
not being in sync on this you know
something Ross we've talked on your
podcast about you know the NFL pays made
a couple statements about Kaepernick but
it's been like you said eight months
nine months it hasn't been a lot it
hasn't been a lot and maybe that's
something behind this that it's just
interesting to me that collusion case is
a big deal and the NFLPA has brought
collusion cases unsuccessfully but about
you know lack of free agency back few
years ago you know they are the people
to bring collusion cases but not here so
almost as a pre-emptive move they put
out a statement saying we'll support
them but we didn't bring this and then
you know the nuclear option Ross
some people have talked about there's a
way you can blow up the whole CBA if you
find collusion well one of the
requirements for that is that the NFLPA
has to bring the case and they're not
bringing the case so we can forget about
that so okay so there's a couple more
questions I've got for year we're
talking with Andrew Brandt yeah he is a
lawyer he's the former Packers executive
who it is the who does the the case go
to Andrew and in your mind you've been
in the owners meetings because the
Packers don't have an owner so you were
at the owners meetings for the Packers
do you think there's any chance that
this actually happened I don't I mean
certainly there have may been internal
conversations about Colin Kaepernick
that involved more than football I think
that's pretty likely but I don't think
coordinated action about this would have
happened I just think that's too out
there and I will say this that you know
when when
people talk about colin kaepernick it's
another level right people are its to
say it's just about football is really
naive and I think that has grown the
longer he's been out that has grown I've
said this for months
he becomes much less of a story if
someone signs him it's a two days story
he's a backup now he's a big story
because he a hasn't talked and B hasn't
signed and I think there's this sort of
mythical figure about him which is going
to permeate into these meetings we'll
talk about in a second in terms of who
here's at Ross system arbitrator that's
the system between the NFL and NFL PA
it's about to collect Oberon agreement
his name is Stephen Burbank he's a law
professor at University of Pennsylvania
he heard the previous collusion case he
heard the cat penalties cases about the
Redskins and Cowboys he'll hear this
case if it gets that far
so is this career over now basically I
mean once you file a collusion grievance
against the NFL
is there any chance a team would
actually sign him that's going to be a
hard thing to do you know obviously
people would would connect the dots here
if a team signs him he drops the case
you know we would sort of think that
would happen if we get there but it
doesn't help you know he's now set in
motion
another antagonistic move and that's not
good I know a lot of people are asking
me about my former team and the sad news
about Aaron whether they'll approach
Colin Kaepernick I think whether it's
Colin Kaepernick Tony Romo or any of the
veteran just speaking about the Packers
we know the Packers I know them so well
they draft and develop they move from
within next man up that next man is
Brett Hundley I think he'll be better
than he was they bring up Callahan from
the practice squad they're good to go so
this idea that you have to jump in for a
veteran whether it's Kaepernick or
anyone else I don't think that's
happening in Green Bay you can hear him
every week on the business of sports
podcast he joins me as well on the Ross
Tucker football podcast on Wednesdays
his name
Andrew Brandt the last question Andrew
these owners meetings and these
discussions they're supposedly having
about anthem protests and putting a rule
out what's gonna happen what do you
anticipate there I think it's a big time
meeting I think it's something that
ultimately like everything Ross comes
down to a negotiation and the NFL owners
want to move on they want to stick to
sports especially on gameday they don't
want this permeating their business and
maybe they're hearing from fans and
sponsors and networks the same thing
players at least a segment of them don't
want to move on so how do they co-opt
how do they become a negotiation there's
talk about the owners letting them use
websites owners having a bootcamp about
social issues owners getting involved in
lobbying for criminal legislation about
racial relations will that satisfy
players it just seems like we're in the
midst of a negotiation defining moment
for the Commissioner for the Union they
you know Dee Smith and Roger Goodell are
both extended or at least pending
extensions here's an opportunity to show
some ability to harmonize for once over
an issue that seems to be polarizing I'm
looking for some kind of bilateral
solution player leadership whether it's
Michael Jenkins Mountain I'm sorry
Malcolm Jenkins Michael Bennett whoever
is satisfied and then the players stand
for the anthem interesting time it
really is Andrew always interesting when
you join me no matter what platform it
might be on thank you so much for the
time always a pleasure rot the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience